mourad n'aime pas quelqu'un sait
[Rires]
[Musique]
pourquoi tu n'aimes pas maxime quoi
c'est clair vis bien choquant parce que
tout simplement pour moi personnellement
j'attends le haut en tout cas ça devrait
donc s comme tuer ce qui concerne pas
maxime gagné moi je peux pas te guérit
[Rires]
maxime kahn et son épouse et la
collector super super c'est sincère non
mais parce que justement pas tes scoop
sont faibles titioro kitty moreau pour
moi c'était monsieur scoop médias et toi
tu l'a remplacé et malheureusement c'est
pas trop ça a justement pas attendre le
ballon
s'il te plaît mais te dire que également
il ya trois-quatre jours tu as sorti un
scoop lequel il veut te le dire c'était
pour toi c'est je pense quitter ton
scoop de teint jours de la journée de la
semaine et découvre les hélicos voilà
savoir que des hits cours vont survoler
la picardie l'auvergne justement pas
m'emballer je m'emballe heck
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'un poids de la voix a ni à me stress
mental mais m'agace m'énerve je te jure
mêmes foot à y voir une entente fini une
orthophoniste ou un coach vocal tu te
bats pas tu vas sortir un billet cyril
barça parce que justement parce et c'est
vraiment agaçant ensuite c'est sans fin
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il est susceptible kelly alors savoir
laquelle il y a justement pas et moi au
moins j'ai très envie d'avoir comme pote
cyril parce que ta range tellement le
coup bah oui tu avais tu fais un pas
décisif vers 0 h toujours je te ment pas
ah ouais but gros vite tu vois cette
agence mais le gardien tu tire à côté
[Rires]
levy est vraiment charmant mars est
vraiment très mignonne en plus je te
mords pas chez célibataire maxime lui
fait rien il reste sur sa chaise en plus
voilà bois il a bradé molosses j'aime
bien la chose est éliminé mais il a
l'air un peu jeune non pourquoi attaquer
la has et là je sais pas alors que la
maturité sakal elle brode là j'ai eu mes
23 ans attaqué la c1 et 28 mai lors de
l'anniversaire mardi
c'est quoi ta paris le 28 ouais
ah oui mais c'est gratuit mais qu'est ce
que j'en ai à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui dénigrent d'un chroniqueur direct il
fait du coup de braque si maxime savait
qu'il se soit on dit toute la vérité
ouais on peut pas être aimé de tout le
monde laissez-moi répondre à moi moi je
les ai je les ai quand même
non mais c'est vrai alors maximiles mal
à choisir juste avant il est très
probable et il se croit au débat des
primaires il variait pas nous comparer
avec thierry moreau se conseille de
regarder ses news il est très bon dans
la matinale donc les stocks plus tôt et
qui leur a dit la soeur véritablement
les concernant les scoops les scoop it
oh tu sais très bien que c'est pour les
séquences pour faire rire c'est de cyril
le pro on en rigole et sur le truc de la
carte aux trésors ina j'imagine beaucoup
de téléspectateurs qui ne savaient pas
qu'ils avaient des nouveaux hélicoptères
qui survolaient la ville
fabre elle avait beaucoup qui le savait
pas mais quand on voyage en matinée mais
moi sur ma voix je demande valeur voit
juste pas ton look donc
et c'est le fils du professeur tournesol
et ça c'est sûr qu'on veut un kelly son
numéro c'est le 06 08
c'était une bonne voie